foreign
[Music]
thank you so I
I was thinking earlier like what idiot
scheduled this talk at this time and
like because immediately afterwards I
have to go and introduce Jeff for the
keynote and of course the idiot uh was
me
so today I want to give you a bit of a
first look at this new oop system for
our called R7 and obviously like I'm
giving this talk but I didn't do all the
work for this talk this is a joint
effort from the our Consortium working
group on object-oriented programming so
talk a little bit about that later
because I think that's a really
important part of this project this is
not just like some idea that I've I've
had it's a team effort from a number of
very important stakeholders in the our
community
but to begin I wanted to kind of talk
about like why do we need oop
and I want to do that by talking about
this sort of this Bizarro function and
the the goal of this Bizarro function is
to take an R object and turn it upside
down somehow so for example if we've got
a numeric Vector maybe we'll flip the
sign
or if we've got a logical Vector maybe
I'll turn trues to falses and falses to
truce
or if I've got a character Victor I'll
flip the letters in each of the strings
in that vector
or if I've got a factor I'll flip the
levels
and if there's anything else I'll just
throw an error
so
what's wrong with this function
well there's nothing really wrong with
this function because it's so simple
like you can already see it on one slide
but there are some problems with this
kind of General approach
and the first one is like as we handle
more and more types of data this
function is going to get bigger and
bigger and bigger and you're gonna have
to have all of that code in a single
file
and if you think about functions in base
r that have to have different behavior
for different types of things this is
going to become really problematic and I
think the function in base r that does
the most different things for the most
different types of objects is print
and if you were to write print
with this kind of if-l style like this
is what it looks like just for the the
types of objects in base r that begin
with the letter A like that's already
not enough to fit on a slide and I
haven't even included the
implementations so you can imagine as
this gets as you deal with more and more
types of things it's going to get bigger
and bigger and bigger
and the other possibly more important
problem is that there's only one person
who can add new types of behavior to
their function to connect and teach that
function to handle new types of object
and that's the original author
and again you can imagine for our core
like if every time someone added a new
type of thing a new class that some code
and R itself would have to change that's
obviously going to be a huge huge hassle
so that's really the inspiration for oo
programming in r
but there are already
two types of O systems in r so why do we
have this well how does R7 fit in well
first of all we have S3 or Mama Bear
now S3 was it has its name because it
was the oop system developed for the
third version of the S programming
language it really is the simplest oop
system that could possibly work it works
basically mostly on conventions it
doesn't have a lot of structure and it
you know it works great but it's very
very simple
and then a few years later as kind of a
reaction to history Along Came Papa Bill
S4
and S4 is very strict very rigorous it's
a lot you get a lot more guarantees but
it's also a lot more complicated and a
lot more work
so S4 so-called because it was designed
for the fourth version of the S
programming language
and so now we've been working on this
tool called R7 where we want to be try
we want to try and be like baby bear we
want to be like just right we want to
strike the right balance between
complexity and power and recalling in
our Stephen because it's hopefully like
three plus four like the best parts of
S3 and S4 and it's designed for ah not
for like backward compatibility with
this
so what would it look like if we were
going to implement this Bizarro function
in R7 well the first thing we have to do
is load the R7 package and this is kind
of probably temporary So currently R7 is
just a package on GitHub hopefully in a
few months it'll become a package on
cran but the long-term goal is to get it
into R itself so this doesn't this is
not an additional dependency this is
something that's built into R but for
now we're going to load that package
and then we're going to create a generic
and a generic is a special type of
function whose behavior depends on the
type of one or more of the functions
so here we're defining a new generic and
crazily enough we're going to use a
function called new generic to do that
and we're going to give that function
the name of the generic so Bizarro and
we're also going to store that result in
a variable called Bizarro that is going
to be our generic
so it's a little bit unfortunate that
we've got to have this repetition here
we're saying Bizarro twice we considered
a number of kind of ways to work around
this and decided that this is the least
worst solution was this this little bit
of repetition
there's one other argument here and that
is the name of the argument that's going
to be used for dispatch dispatch is the
process of finding the implementation
given the type of the argument
so this generic like doesn't really do
anything there's no code here right
there's no implementation but it kind of
defines the shape of what this function
is going to look like
and if we want to add implementation
what we have to do is Define methods
so if we go back to that Bizarro
function look at that first if block if
is numeric X
what we're going to do now instead of an
if block is we're going to define a
method and we're going to Define that
method with the method function
so the first argument of the method is
the generic
and the second argument to the generic
is the type of object we want to provide
an implementation or a method for and so
here we're going to use a built-in class
this is something a numeric vectors are
something that come built into R
something that R7 is going to provide
for you and then we provide the
implementation which is exactly the same
as before so the implementation has not
changed but the way we get to that
implementation instead of having a bunch
of FL statements we're going to use this
this method lookup
and so if we work through the other
methods The Logical exactly the same
thing now instead of testing if it is
not logical we say we're defining a
method for the bizarre generic with a
logical class
the same thing for character and so on
and once we've done that
the generic is going to work exactly the
same way as our original function
nothing's going to differ there except
that when we call it with some type of
object we haven't provided a method for
we're going to get a slightly different
error message because we're going to say
that the R7 R7 system is going to say
well I can't find a method for an object
that's a function
if we print that generic we can see that
this is an RC of a generic that has a
bunch of methods
and if you're paying attention you might
notice that there are four methods there
but I only just defined three methods
and that's because the numeric class is
is a little bit of affection and R there
isn't really such a thing as a numeric
Vector a numeric Vector is either
actually an integer vector or a double
vector and that's what you can see in
this class
now you've probably always you've
probably seen a similar thing if you've
ever printed an S3 generic
but this is what an S3 generic looks
like
so if you've ever been hunting for the
source code for a function and you see
this weird use method called that tells
you you're dealing with an S3 generic
and so one of the things we've tried to
do with our C event is to be a little
bit help more helpful when you look at a
generic it's going to tell you hey this
is a generic and these are the methods
that I know about
and those four methods there which look
like function calls those are actually
function calls and if you copy and paste
that code into your console you'll see
the implementation of each of those
methods
so there are two parts to
object-oriented programming systems and
uh generics generic functions which
Define behavior and classes which Define
data so I've shown you generics and now
I want to show you a little bit about
what classes in R7 look like
so I'm going to create a new class
surprise surprise I'm going to use a
function called new class to do that
I'm going to call it a range class again
I'm going to assign the result of that
function to an object with the same name
as the class and that is going to
produce what we call the Constructor
function this is both kind of a
definition of the class and the thing
you're going to use to create instances
or objects of that class
this class has some properties so
properties are the data that an object
possesses if you've used S3 before this
is the same as attributes if you've used
S4 these are the same as slots
so these are the the data that each that
every object of this range class is
going to possess everyone is going to
have a start property and an end
property that are both numeric vectors
so now that we've created that object
that class object that class Constructor
we can create range objects just by
calling that function we can print it we
get some information about the data
that's in it and we get this hint that
maybe we can access the values inside
that object with the ad symbol
so if you've ever used S4 before that's
the way you extract data out of objects
in S4 with that and R7 takes that
so you can get values you can see it
values but R7 has kind of got some
built-in safety rails so if you try and
assign a character Vector to that X
property that we said had to be a
numeric
you're going to get an error
but that doesn't protect you against
every possible error every possible way
you might create an invalid object
because you might say well actually I
want to have a range object where the
start is always less than the end and
there's currently nothing stopping me
from creating invalid ranges just by
using a larger start than an end
we can resolve that in our statement by
providing something called a validator a
validator is just a function that takes
an object and either says all as well or
it returns a message telling you what is
wrong with that object
and so once you supply a validator then
that is going to ensure that every
instance of that object has to be valid
it's very well it's still it's R it's
still possible to create an invalid
object but you've got to jump through
some hoops to do that
and this is a really valuable very
valuable property because this means
that if you have a range object you know
that start is always going to be less
than end you know that these conditions
are true which is really useful
another really cool thing you can do is
you can make properties that are that
aren't actually data
that are computed on demand they behave
exactly as if there was some data behind
them but uh you can do basically
anything you want inside these
properties so these work a little look
like um
active bindings if you've used those
before
but this is a really important aspect of
R7 which which I'll come back to a
little bit later
so that that's kind of our seven in a
nutshell
but how does it kind of compare to us it
to S3 and S4 well I think if we're going
to compare our systems it's good to
think about like what's the complexity
how hard it is to use and what's the
payoff
and S3 has a very very low complexity
it's very very simple and the payoff is
relatively low
S4 the payoff is much much higher but
the complexity is also much much higher
and so our goal with R7 is to create
something that's just a little bit more
complex than S3 but has almost all of
the features all of the payoff of S4
now whenever I hear about someone trying
to solve a problem with his two existing
solutions by creating a third solution I
always think of this XKCD comic
and we really want to avoid this with R7
we don't want to make the whole problem
more complicated by now giving people
three possible choices of
object-oriented programming instead of
the the two that are baked into base are
not to mention like the the five or six
other packages on cran that have uh
other object-on programming systems
so how are we going to do that well
first of all this is a team effort the
our Consortium working group on
object-owned programming is the mouthful
includes representatives from our core
from bioconductor from our open SCI from
Austria tidy verse and the general art
community this is not an effort to solve
the problems of just a small group of
people but this is an effort to solve
the problems faced by a large proportion
of the our community
next we're trying to take what we
believe to be the best parts of S4 and
keep them and there's like the formal
definition of classes so when you get an
object of a specific type you know a
bunch about it right off the bat
that that at helper which gives you a
useful error message if you try to
extract something that does not exist
R7 also provides multiple dispatch when
needed which is really important for
errorflake for example arithmetic
operations or you need to need to choose
the implementation implementation based
on the left hand side and the right hand
side of addition
and finally we have like this validator
function which allows us to apply
additional conditions to make sure our
objects are valid
and we've tried to do that while keeping
our Stephen a hundred percent Backward
Compatible with S3 so if you have an
existing S3 class you can convert it to
R7 in such a way that everyone who uses
that object is if it's an RCA of an
object it's all of these new goodies but
no existing code breaks
and one of the ways we've done this is a
little is a little weird in terms of the
spectrum of object-owned programming
systems and other environments so one of
the core kind of precepts of O
programming is normally encapsulation
and that means like only the person who
like writes a class can access the data
inside that class
and this this is I think a really good
idea in like 99 of programming languages
but it doesn't really work in R because
the people who use are a data scientist
and they want that data inside that
object and they will do whatever it
takes to get that object if they want it
to get that data if they want it so S4
tried to kind of protect people from
this like the you're never as a user
you're not really supposed to use the ad
symbol you're always supposed to use
some kind of access a function but it
just didn't really work people want that
data and so instead our Stephen has
designed around like rather than trying
to fight this very natural tendency R7
accepts it while giving you the ability
to change the internals of your of your
class if you need to with these Dynamic
properties so if you have to you can
change the internal implementation you
can deprecate Fields properties inside
your object and still have existing code
work which is really important property
to allow code to evolve over time
and then finally we've tried to dig a
pit of success with uh thoughtful
function names argument names
documentation and errors so hopefully
after you've used a little bit you can
start to guess what the code you need is
and if that guess is slightly wrong you
will get useful feedback that points you
in the right direction
so really really appreciate it if you
would try out R7 as I said it's
currently a GitHub package which you can
install pretty easily if you want we'd
love to know not just what doesn't work
or how it doesn't help you solve your
problems but we also want to know like
what doesn't make sense what don't you
understand
like where are the problems in the
documentation where are the problems in
the error messages so that we can do
better and that we can make R7 just
right
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]